parmi les légendes
sonnée la culture européenne il y en a
eu
et de nourrir l'image
grand public la légende arthurienne
née au début du moyen-âge la légende du
roi arthur contient tous les ingrédients
des grands récits mythiques héros une
quête des épreuves à surmonter et des
adversaires à vaincre
arthur est roi de bretagne selon la
légende les dieux l'aurait désigné pour
organiser la quête du graal un
mystérieux objet ayant recueilli le sang
du christ qui procurerait à son
détenteur des pouvoirs insoupçonnés
preuve de son élection divine arthur
serait le seul à pouvoir s'emparer
d'excalibur une épée magique ne pouvons
être extraite de son rocher que par un
être pur
et qui d'autre est celui qui la maîtrise
de l'invincibilité
au 20e siècle nombreux sont les artistes
et les intellectuels qui continue à
explorer la figure du roi arthur et la
légende qui l'entourent
c'est le cas d'alexandre astier qui
réalisera une série télévisée nommé
camelot du nom du château vive le roi
arthur et qui sera diffusé sur les
écrans de 2005 à 2009
humoristique dans les premières saisons
la série prendra une orientation de plus
en plus sombre et dramatique mettant en
exergue les difficultés rencontrées par
arthur son mal être existentiel et sa
quête de sens jamais résolu entouré de
chevalier plus incompétents les uns que
les autres arthur patauge dans sa
mission il voulait incarner la figure
d'un roi juste et volontaire mais les
affaires courantes du royaume a ajouté à
la bêtise de ses subordonnés l'enfant
seront dans une solitude de plus en plus
inextricable
une solitude qui lui fera côtoyé le
tragique et l'absurde
mais si on devait dresser le portrait
philosophique du roi arthur qu'est ce
que ça donnerait quels sont les
philosophies qui influence sans qu'il le
sache la vision du monde du roi arthur
c'est ce que je vous propose de
découvrir dans cet épisode
[Musique]
lorsqu'on s'intéresse à la psychologie
d'arthur tel que l'a imaginé alexandre
astier un premier aspect de sa
personnalité saute immédiatement aux
yeux
arthur n'est pas heureux contraint de se
marier à une femme qu'il n'aime pas noyé
sous les doléances et privés de toute
stimulation intellectuelle
arthur s'ennuie les rares fois où on le
voit esquissé un sourire c'est pour
exprimer son exaspération
ou parce que cherchant à évacuer la
pression il sera retombé en enfance le
temps d'un jeu improvisé s'il semble peu
enclin à la violence et au ressentiment
arthur n'en demeure pas moins un
personnage austère la morosité domine
son quotidien est ironiquement ce sont
ses prises de bec avec son entourage qui
lui fournissent les seules occasions de
se distraire
mais chez arthur la morosité ne
constitue pas seulement un trait de
caractère
elle a une origine plus profondes
arthur schopenhauer disait que la vie
aussi laid comme un pendule de la
souffrance à l'ennui l'homme est un être
de désir il éprouve un manque lorsqu il
n'obtient pas ce qu'il veut et quand il
l'obtient sa satisfaction le plonge dans
l'ennui
souffrent ses ennuis constituerait ainsi
les deux facettes de l'existence quand
ce n'est pas l'ennui qui ronge le roi
arthur c'est la souffrance la souffrance
d'une vie qui n'a pas réellement choisi
la souffrance de ne pas voir ses efforts
reconnu la souffrance d'une descendance
qu'il recherchera sans jamais la trouver
comme schopenhauer arthur vit dans la
conscience de la médiocrité humaine
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
ils cultivent la solitude car comme
disait schopenhauer la solitude offre à
l'homme intelligent le double avantage
d'être avec soi même et de ne pas être
avec les autres
ironie du sort le seul personnage pour
lequel arthur éprouvent un réel respect
est aussi celui qui deviendra son
principal rival lance l'eau lancelot
qu'arthur recrutera sans hésiter après
avoir constaté qu'il était comme lui
comme lui exigeant envers les autres et
envers lui même
l'ennui d'arthur vient du fait qu'il
évolue dans la médiocrité à peine assis
sur le trône il comprend que sa plus
grande tâche ne sera pas de remporter
des batailles mais de supporter
l'incompétence de ceux qui sont censés
l'y aider le fait de rencontrer lancelot
lui redonnera espoir et motivation
l'espace de quelques minutes arthur
oublie que les êtres humains sont
médiocres et cet oubli prend la forme
d'un sourire ce même sourire
qu'affichent les deux protagonistes du
film heat auquel alexandre astier rend
plusieurs fois hommage dans la série
mais l'ennui d'arthur pourrait-il avoir
une autre origine
pascal disait que tout le malheur des
hommes venaient de leur incapacité à
demeurer en repos dans une chambre
demeurer en repos dans une chambre c'est
être confronté à soi-même à la solitude
et à la pensée de notre mort prochaine
le divertissement nous détournent de l'
angoisse de la mort
que ce soit par le jeu par le plaisir ou
même par le travail nous avons besoin
d'une occupation qui nous fera oublier
cette angoisse c'est d'ailleurs le sens
littéral du mot divertir dévié détourner
un roi sans divertissement est un homme
plein de misère a ajouté pascal
soulignant par là que même les plus
hautes responsabilités ne suffisent pas
à conjurer l'ennui et l'angoissé de la
mort
arthur a besoin de divertissement un
divertissement qu'il trouvera dans la
compagnie de ses maîtresses mais aussi
plus étonnamment dans quelques moments
de discussion avec perceval le seul
personnage à l'égard duquel arthur
semble éprouver une véritable affection
arthur est officiellement un roi
chrétien le père blaise assure la
conformité des lois du royaume avec la
doctrine chrétienne jusque dans le
respect des intervalles musicaux mais
très peu porté sur la religion arthur
reste insensible à la foi chrétienne et
ne manifeste aucun penchant à la
transcendance l'idée d'une vie céleste
après la mort lui est étrangère et ne
lui ai donc d'aucun secours pour apaiser
son angoisse la seule échappatoire
d'arthur caylar le théâtre comme
lorsqu'il explique à perceval les
principes du schéma agde en ciel la
musique la chanson à la volette
constituant l'un des plus célèbre
comique de répétition de la série ou
encore la poésie comme dans l'épisode le
jour d'alexandre dans lequel arthur
imposent aux habitants du royaume que le
temps d'une journée il s'exprime
uniquement envers de 12 syllabes
là encore arthur rejoint schopenhauer
qui voyaient dans l'art le seul moyen de
neutraliser temporairement la souffrance
de l'existence car si arthur est un
personnage désabusé son âme d'enfant
trouve encore de quoi s'émerveiller
devant la beauté de la création
artistique
l'émotion esthétique et la contemplation
comme remède à l'ennui
[Applaudissements]
si l'art et le divertissement permettent
à arthur de soulager son mal être
existentiel une valeur plus fondamental
semble guider son rapport au monde le
sens de la justice
arthur est un roi progressiste il a à
coeur de défendre les pauvres et les
opprimés
quand bien même ces derniers ne lui
témoignerait pas la gratitude qu'il
mérite il accède aux doléances de ces
paysans affranchi des esclaves s'oppose
à la peine de mort et refusent de
profiter de son privilège d'envahisseurs
lorsqu ils assiègent un village ennemis
on l'a vu
arthur est dépourvue de toute foi
religieuse mais il n'en demeure pas
moins un homme moral
conscient que tout ne se fait pas et
qu'il y a des causes qui méritent qu'on
se sacrifie pour elle devrait pour la
justice donne du sens aux règnes
d'arthur pour lui être roi ne signifie
pas seulement gouverneur royaume être
roi signifier se battre pour la dignité
des faibles un enseignement qu'il
recevra de césar en personne
césar que le jeune arthur admire pour
son génie militaire mais qui lui
apprendra que la réalité du pouvoir
tiens d'abord à ce qu'on en fait
arthur a pour surnom le juste à surnom
qui lui vaudra les moqueries de son
beau-père léodagan le sanguinaire pour
qui le juste aurait tout aussi bien pu
s'appeler le gentillet
mais ces quolibets n'atteignent pas
arthur qui persiste à vouloir incarner
la figure d'un roi équitable et intègre
ce cas concret arthur c'est qu'être
juste ne signifie pas être faible être
juste c'est au contraire avoir le
courage de ne pas faire reposer son
autorité sur la peur
de par son attachement à la justice
arthur rejoint les prescriptions d'un
philosophe et théologien du moyen-âge
saint thomas d'aquin saint thomas
d'aquin disait la force d'une loi dépend
de son degré de justice pour saint
thomas d'aquin comme pour arthur il est
impératif qu'une loi soit juste le
pouvoir ne justifie pas tout et le roi
n'est pas moins soumis qu'un autre au
devoir de vertu et de probité une vision
qu'arthur est le seul à défendre entouré
de chefs d'état qui estime que l'intérêt
d'être roi c'est précisément de n'obéir
à rien ni à personne
arthur obéit à ce qu'il pense être son
devoir cette conscience morale lui
portera souvent préjudice car en plus de
le faire passer pour un roi mollasson
elle génère en lui dilemme et
culpabilité
arthur est habité par le doute et ce
doute atteindra son point culminant dans
le livre 5 lorsqu'il replantera
excalibur dans son rocher
geste qui signifie qu'il renonce à son
titre de roi de bretagne
il est à noter que le seul qui ne
tentera pas de retirer l'épée c'est
encore une fois perceval par fidélité à
arthur qu'il continuera à appeler sir
un choix scénaristiques qui ne doit
évidemment rien au hasard quand on sait
que perceval a lui aussi le pouvoir de
maîtriser excalibur et qu'il aurait donc
pris la place d'arthur s'il avait tenté
sa chance mais sans doute n'était ce pas
encore son heure
dans tous les cas il est révélateur que
les deux personnages désigné par les
dieux pour régner sur la bretagne soit
aussi les deux personnages à ne pas
s'estimer légitime assurer cette
fonction
comme si l'intégrité et le sens de la
justice allait de pair avec le doute et
le sentiment d'illégitimité
comme si les élus étaient les derniers à
admettre qu'ils sont les élus
dans le livre 6 nous remontons à
l'époque où arthur apprend qu'il a été
choisi pour occuper le trône de bretagne
stupéfait il ne comprend pas cette
décision car il se considère incompétent
mais surtout illégitime là où n'importe
qui d'autre que lui sauterait sur
l'occasion arthur hésite parce qu'il a
conscience de la responsabilité
qu'implique un tel statut son syndrome
de l'imposteur fera même l'objet d'un
dialogue entre lui et césar qui lui
confiera que pour devenir légitime il
faut commencer par faire semblant faire
semblant jusqu'au jour où il n'y aura
plus besoin de faire semblant
jusqu'au jour où l'habitude aura fait
disparaître le doute
le sens de la justice d'arthur ce
manifeste jusque dans sa manière de
punir les délits et les crimes
arthur fait preuve de clémence et de
pondération comme dans l'épisode 13 du
livre 1 où ils refusent de pratiquer la
torture sur un voleur ou dans l'épisode
14 du livre iii dans lequel est gracile
et prisonnier qui je cite n'ont rien
fait de gravissime
l'exécution stricte et mécanique des
peines les plus sévères lui apparaît
comme absurdes et quand une loi est
enfreinte il estime qu'il faut tenir
compte du contexte et de la gravité
réelle des faits
on retrouve également cette idée chez
saint thomas d'aquin pour lequel ce qui
est condamnable c'est de suivre la loi à
la lettre quand il ne le faut pas c'est
la différence entre la lettre de la loi
à savoir ce que disent les textes
juridiques et l'esprit de la loi ce que
la loi s'attache à combattre
saint thomas d'aquin prend comme exemple
une loi qui obligerait à restituer un
objet à son propriétaire et qui si on
l'appliqué à la lettre obligerait donc à
rendre son arme à un dément au risque
qu'ils commettent un crime dans ce cas
appliquer la loi c'est aller contre
l'esprit de la loi pour arthur une
société juste n'est pas une société dans
laquelle on tue les criminels mais dans
laquelle on fait en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas de crime et ça ça passe par créer
les conditions de la justice il fait
construire des écoles répondre aux
doléances des paysans remplacent les
esclavages par le travail comme pour
mieux donner à chacun les moyens de sa
propre émancipation
arthur n'aime pas particulièrement les
gens mais ils les respectent comme il
respecte le peuple breton a couru sur le
rivage pour faire corps derrière lui
lorsqu'il défi l'armée romaine
car c'est ainsi qu'il conçoit de
défendre la dignité des faibles en les
rendant acteurs de leur propre élévation
en leur insufflant la force qui leur
manque pour devenir les rois de leur
propre destinée
[Musique]
au delà des bienfaits qu'ils apportent à
son royaume arthur demeure un roi
tourmenté
la dépression dans laquelle il s'enfonce
année après année ne laisse aucune place
au doute
arthur a un problème avec la vie
son déclin psychologique n'est que le
symptôme d'une crise intérieure beaucoup
plus profonde
cette crise c'est l'absurdité de
l'existence
arthur est intelligent et comme toute
personne intelligente il s'interroge
l'arbitraire et le hasard ne constitue
pas pour lui des réponses satisfaisantes
arthur a besoin de sens et ce sens il ne
parvient pas à le trouver
le graal reste pour lui un mystère de
même que les raisons pour lesquelles il
a été placé sur le trône de bretagne
s'entendre dire qu'il est l'élu des
dieux ne résout en aucun cas l'énigme
pourquoi lui
pourquoi le besoin d'être élu pourquoi
les dieux se mêle-t-il de nos affaires
dès qu'on croit tenir une réponse
l'horizon des questions recul faisant
naître chez arthur le sentiment de
l'absurde et du néant existentielle
la vie quotidienne d'arthur est marqué
par la répétition les réunions de la
table ronde où les chevaliers rivalisent
d'improductivité les repas avec ses
beaux parents alimenté par les disputes
et les conflits d'ego les soirées
abstinente avec guenièvre quand tout le
royaume attend un héritier
au fil du temps ce climat de routine et
d'immobilité va générer chez arthur un
sentiment d'inutilité et de vide
l'impression que les jours se suivent et
se ressemblent et que la condition de
roi ne vaut pas mieux que celle d'un
animal dans une roue
[Musique]
le format des deux premières saisons de
camelot est à l'image de cette
répétition des épisodes courts sans lien
chronologique et où l'intriguent paraît
ne jamais avancé puis à partir du livre
iii les éléments scénaristiques
s'enclenche dans des épisodes plus long
pour donner lieu aux véritables enjeux
dramatiques de la série l'abandon
progressif par arthur de sa mission
lassé de faire des efforts inutilement
arthur s'isole et cet isolement sera le
prélude à une crise intérieure qui ira
en s'accentuant dans le livre iii il
entame une relation adultère avec
m'évanouis ce qui provoquera le départ
de guenièvre et accessoirement la colère
des dieux
à ce moment précis du récit arthur met
le doigt dans l'engrenage tragique le
point de non-retour dont il ne se
relèvera pas
dans le vocabulaire théâtral la martias
désigne le moment où le héros tragique
commet la faute qui entraînera sa chute
les éléments du tragique se met alors en
place indépendamment de la volonté et
des actions du héros quoi qu'il fasse le
héros tragique subir à la fatalité
si on analyse l'évolution du personnage
d'arthur danone naïf on pourrait croire
qu arthur est un roi qui perd
progressivement le contrôle de sa vie
mal entouré manquant d'exaltation arthur
aurait tout simplement renoncé à une
mission pour laquelle il n'avait ni le
tempérament ni les épaules mais une
autre interprétation est possible le
renoncement d'arthur est en fait le seul
moyen qu'ils les trouvaient pour
conjurer le cycle de la répétition
la répétition et la marque de l'absurde
elle rend inenvisageable
l'idée de progrès puisque chaque
nouvelle action débouche sur le ré
enclenchement du cycle initial
dans ce contexte commettre une faute
c'est ouvrir une issue dans le
labyrinthe de l'absurde c'est briser le
cycle de la répétition seul moyen pour
le héros de donner du sens à son
existence
rien de grand ne s'est accompli dans le
monde sans passion disait hegel en
introduisant de la passion dans la
répétition arthur n'aurait-il pas
inconsciemment créer les conditions de
son réveil
albert camus disait que le seul problème
philosophique vraiment sérieux c'était
le suicide en mettant un terme à la vie
le suicide mais simultanément un terme à
l'absurdité de l'existence et à la
souffrance qui en découlent pourquoi
vivre si nous savons que nous allons
mourir pourquoi vivre si la vie n'est
qu'une parenthèse d'insignifiance dans
un monde qui n'a pas besoin de nous dans
le livre 5 arthur part à la recherche de
sa descendance ses nombreuses aventures
sans lendemain lui font espérer qu'il y
ait quelque part un enfant dont il soit
le père cette recherche en la forme
d'une véritable quête existentielle
surpassant en valeur et en intensité la
quête du graal
l'enfance c'est l'innocence et arthur
insistent plusieurs fois dans la série
sur le fait qu'il tient à être un modèle
pour les enfants la quête de la
descendance c'est la quête de
l'innocence le graal métaphysique
l'innocence qui répond à toutes les
questions
l'innocence qui fait qu'on ne se pose
plus de questions mais la descendance
c'est aussi la perpétuation
se prolonger au delà de soi et ainsi
repousser les limites du temps et de sa
propre finitude
avoir un enfant c'est transférer la
question du sens sur un être pur qui
nous sommes tous
arthur est en quête de pureté et cette
pureté il la trouvera en perceval un
personnage loufoque mais fidèle stupide
mais lucide dont alexandre astier dira
bien qu'il ne l'a pas écrit comme un
idiot mais comme un enfant
perceval est l'archétype de l'innocence
c'est à dire littéralement de la non
nocivité
là où arthur m la pureté perceval la
pratique raison pour laquelle sans doute
excalibur brille davantage quand c'est
perceval qui la tient indice probable
que lorsque l'heure sera venue perceval
succédera à arthur sur le tronc de
bretagne et qu'il trouvera le graal
ce graal qui à l'image de la pierre
philosophale des alchimistes ne seront
accessibles qu'à celui qui n'en a plus
besoin à celui dont la pureté et la
sagesse rente insignifiant les biens
matériels
perceval ces lettres pur auquel arthur
apporte la sagesse c'est le fils car tu
en as jamais yeux
[Musique]
dans le livre 5 arthur est manipulé par
un être maléfique envoyés par les dieux
pour le punir d'avoir abdiqué il se
nomme mêlée à gand la réponse la réponse
des dieux à l'affront d'un homme la
réponse de l'ordre cosmique à celui qui
s'est révolté contre l'arbitraire des
dieux parce qu'il n'en voyait pas le
sens
mêlée à gand envoûtera une pythie pour
qu'elle fasse croire à arthur qu'il est
un fait qu'on le but de la manoeuvre
c'est d'enfoncer arthur dans sa
dépression et dans son sentiment de
vacuité existentielle
non content d'avoir échoué dans la quête
du graal il aura échoué à se perpétuer
et son absence de descendance résonne
comme la confirmation d'une usine
n'ayant aucun sens
condamné par les dieux arthur tentera de
mettre fin à ses jours en se taillant
les veines dans sa baignoire
tous les suicidés sont le christ dire
arthur toutes les baies noires sont le
graal le graal qui a recueilli le sang
du christ le sang des martyrs le sang
d'un suicide est mort volontairement
pour nous faire comprendre que le mal
vient de nous
et que nous pouvons y mettre un terme si
nous le décidons
si le graal et le récipient qui a
recueilli le sang du christ alors le
graal et la conscience du mal parmi les
hommes
nous avons tué un innocent et le graal
est le réceptacle de ce péché
lorsque lancelot découvre arthur dans sa
baignoire alors qu'il était venu pour
l'assassiner il le sauver
tuer son rival avait un sens le sauver
en a davantage
lancelot c'est nous
doter d'excalibur arthur l'invincible ne
pouvait mourir au combat son véritable
combat fut celui du sens et sa mort ne
pouvait que venir de ses propres mains
mais extirper de la mort par son ennemi
arthur se trouve à replacer dans le
circuit du sens notre vie doit être
précieuse pour que notre adversaire
veille la sauver le graal est la réponse
à l'absurdité de l'existence
il est la conscience de la valeur de la
vie
[Musique]
ennui justice absurde
tels sont les maîtres mots de la
philosophie du roi arthur un personnage
aux antipodes de l'archétype du héros
qui nous rappelle que le tragique se
cache parfois dans la normalité car
camelot ce n'est pas seulement
l'histoire d'un roi c'est l'histoire
d'un homme ordinaire que le destin a
voulu rendre extraordinaire
l'histoire d'un homme avec ses angoisses
ses doutes ses faiblesses comme pour
mieux nous rappeler que nous sommes tous
des élus
car s'il ya un enseignement à retirer du
personnage du roi arthur
c'est que même si nous ne sommes pas des
rois nous avons tous en nous un graal à
conquérir
[Musique]